hello everyone and welcome to the other
semi-final match of the speed Chess
Championship it is Magnus Carlsen versus
Maxima Shiela Grava and the winner of
this match will face Hikaru Nakamura in
the finals of the speed chase
championship and now this is a game from
the five plus one section uh which just
finished I'm not going to mention the
results as we are going to cover at
least one more game from this match but
this is a truly a beauty uh so uh let's
dive straight into it and see what this
is all about it's magnets with the white
pieces and he opens with D4 we're gonna
have a very weird setup right from the
beginning sorry about that
uh Maxim replies with Knight to F6 uh we
have Knight to F3 G6 and now Knight beta
D2 already a very weird setup D5 by
Maxim and now B3 a very very rare been
played only a few times but Magnus is uh
the one person who actually played it
and he played it in a classical event
but we're gonna get back to that Bishop
to G7 Bishop to B2 ended this is the
position that Magnus had this year uh in
the European Club Cup against Marco
baldaufa and he won the game very nicely
in that game uh the the game continued
with Marco castling but here Maxine
plays Bishop to F5 and okay E3 and now
uh Maxine castles and it is now as of
move six that we have a completely new
game uh with Bishop to E2 Nike the E4
and now Magnus castles we have Pawn to
see five striking against the White
Center of course you cannot capture
because the Bushman B2 will hang so
Knight the E5 and excellent where for
the night and now Knight to C6 we have
Knight captures an E4 by Magnus Bishop
captures and now Knight captures and C6
first a nice solution sug B captures on
C6 and pawn to C3 now for the moment
closing up your dark squared Bishop but
once you develop your pieces the uh the
the the bishop will come alive so Maxim
develops the queen connects his Rooks
wants to put pressure on the A2 pawn and
Magnus advances at the A4 and he
prepares such a tricky maneuver uh that
uh is too tricky even for him and even
for Maxine so C captures on the 4 by
Maxine and down while Magnus should
capture on D4 he plays Pawn to B4 and
now okay Maxim's Queen is hanging he
removes it back to B6 but what he should
play is actually the captures on C3
incredible but yes you should give up
your queen here and if B captures an A5
then C captures on B2 and look at the
Bishops here absolute monsters white has
no nothing better than to give up The
Rook here Bishop captures and B1 Queen
captures and now C5 and now look at this
C for C3 this this will be incredible
the Rooks are coming to maybe be it and
see it you're gonna continue pushing if
Rook to D1 you can even defend this pawn
and then put the Rooks behind this Pawn
then Advance the pawn uh it would be
very very difficult to hold this
especially in uh in Blitz but Magnus
tricks Maxim he goes back Queen to B6
and now Pawn to A5 we have Queen to B8
and now only now C captures on D4 we
have Queen captures on B4 and now Bishop
to A3 going after that E6 Pawn sorry
about that Arrow uh Queen to B7
defending the pawn and now Queen to D2
with Rook F to C8 and now Pawn to A6
chasing the queen further back Queen to
C7 and now Pawn to F3 Bishop to F5 and
now Pawn to G4 and here Magnus tricks
Maxine for the second time it seems that
you can't go to D7 because of Bishop
captures on E7 but this is the absolute
best move you should play uh because now
if Magnus captures you can simply
capture on G4 and now its Magnus was in
trouble you have to move the bishop back
then Maxine moves the bishop back and he
completely opened up the white king but
instead he trusted Magnus again he went
Bishop back to E6 and this prevents him
from executing the much needed E5
Central breakthrough so hero Rook 8 to
B1 by Magnus going for that B7 Square
Rook 8 to B8 and now Bishop to C5
putting continuous pressure on that A7
Pawn H5 by Maxine and here this is
already I think uh Maxim starting to get
a bit nervous you have to play a winning
move here and wait for Magnus to go for
something but Maxim goes for the attack
he plays H5 and okay Magnus plays G
counters and H5 he doesn't mind the G
file opening up he can play King uh King
to H1 put the Rook on the G file and go
after the black king but Maxim has
different plans Bishop to F5 and now
Bishop to D3 going after the bishop here
not allowing a maxim to keep an intact
uh structure defending his King E5 now
finally Maxim gets this Central
breakthrough in h capture Sun G6 Bishop
captures bishop captress and g6f
captures and G6 and now Queen to G2 and
now the G file opened up Magnus is going
after the G6 Pawn we have Queen to F7
and now D captures on E5 and here you
have it's an incredibly difficult
position it's hard to find the move here
for Maxime with Queen to F5 you still
hold the position a little bit putting
pressure on that rook and B1 maybe
trying white uh trying to get white then
at the trade on B8 but after Bishop
captures an E5 there is just no
defending this position Magnus goes Pawn
to F4 attacks the bishop Bishop back to
G7 and now Queen G4 puts pressure on the
rook and now trading is impossible uh
because the queen first picks up the
rook and C8 with check and then you
gobble up the second Rook so here Rook
the E8 by Maxim and now Rook capture Sun
V8 a very simple conclusion Rook
captures and now Pawn to F5 this is a
Magnus blasts through the position G
captures an F5 Rook captures an F5
attacking the queen and there's uh not
much but Maxim can do here the bishop is
coming to D4 the bishop is spin you're
not going to be able to move it The Rook
is coming to G5 this pressure is
unbearable Rook to B1 check Maxim tries
a few more checks Rook B2 check King H3
Queen to C7 but now Magnus finishes with
a spectacular move uh black is getting
checkmated so feel free to pause the
video and Checkmate the black key while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on sporting the uh
Unstoppable mate in five and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to f8 that's the good stuff
Rook to f8 check and black resides and
in fact it was in this position that
Maxim vashiella grah resigned to the
game as he is now getting checkmated if
the game continued the game would
continue King H7 and now of course the
bishop cannot move uh the the queen pins
the bishop Queen to H5 check best of the
H6 these are only moves Queen to F5
check King G7 and now a nice Bishop the
D4 check Fork uh you have to block with
the queen queen the E5 this looks
disgusting and now Bishop captures on E5
will be Checkmate so brilliant stuff by
Magnus uh pulling a mind trick twice not
once but twice on on mvl first time with
this spectacular B4 move uh Maxim not
realizing he could play D captures on C3
and then once again after uh he uh
chased away the bishop with the G4
tricked Maxim into thinking Bishop to D7
was not an option uh when it was in fact
the best move so nicely done by Magnus a
very very nice positional Masterpiece I
hope you guys enjoyed this one we'll see
what happens in the rest of the match
still we have the three plus one and the
one plus one uh we'll see how it goes uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Chris
Robert Picard sapambatia Sarah Hamilton
Jonathan
um uh Hiroshi and clothes box for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
this spectacular event until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day